when I was about 15 I had a week of work
experience Americans would call that an
internship but that's not really right
work experiences a thing in British
schools that basically just gets the
older kids out of the way for a few days
and parms them off on local businesses
so the teachers can have a break I can't
actually remember the name of the
company now but anyway they had a
problem they had recently scanned in a
load of photos all the history of the
place but those photos weren't
categorize they just had hundreds maybe
a couple of thousands of pictures all in
one folder with arbitrary file names and
the work experience kid got assigned the
job of going through them all and
writing descriptions well that's boring
I thought cuz of course I did it was
really dull it's the job you give the
work experience kid because they're not
disenchanted enough with the world yet
so in between typing the descriptions I
figured I would show off and I would
write a system to search through them
it'll be like yahoo or that new google
thing that was starting to become
populated it would look great I'd look
really smart I didn't know anything
about how to build that but with utterly
unjustified confidence figured it
couldn't be that make a problem I mean
it wasn't take a search word loop
through all the descriptions count how
many words match and then return all the
matching results sorted by the number of
matches and yeah weld fine until I got
over about 50 photographs at which point
it starts to get a little bit slow after
a hundred it start to get really slow
and I started to spend more time trying
to fix it in less time actually doing my
job actually god I mean I wasn't getting
paid so anyway to explain why my code
sucked let's talk about Big O notation
[Music]
whatever you're coding there are almost
certainly many different ways to
approach the problem but even though all
those approaches can end up with the
same result they may take vastly
different amounts of time or memory to
get there and the best example of that
is sorting an animation like this is a
classic of computer science I remember
seeing demonstrations of things like
this on a dust computer complete with
bleep bloop sound effects for hours tiny
so we've got a bunch of different sized
blocks we've got a list what algorithms
can we use to put our list in order
let's start with something called bubble
sort take the first two blocks and
compare them if the first one is longer
than the second swap them if not leave
them where they are now compare the next
two blocks same again if they are in the
wrong order swap them if they're not
leave them and so on and so on and so on
until we get all the way to the end of
list and at that point we have moved the
biggest block in the list to the very
end and that's all and no it's not very
efficient but it has now been done so
now we can go again from the start we
can compare swap if we need to compare
swap if we need to compare swell if we
need to and so on and so on and so on if
we get all the way start to finish
without moving a thing then we know that
everything is sorted and we can stop and
if not we go back to the start and
eventually after many many many passes
congratulations we have a sorted list
bubble sort will each block bubbling up
is terrible it has to check every block
and list on every pass in most cases it
will have to pass through the list as
many times as there are blocks on it ten
blocks means ten operations performed
ten times a hundred blocks means a
hundred operations performed a hundred
times the number of operations it has to
perform goes up with the square of the
number of blocks which means that it has
a Big O of N squared the foundations of
Big O notation plus that o symbol were
laid down towards the end of the 19th
century by German mathematicians working
in analytic number theory but it was
popularized in computer science by the
great
Donald Knopf in the 1970s Knuth I should
have checked up anyway Big O distills an
algorithm down to a single expression
which indicates how it performs as you
add more blocks more input
running tined it lets you compare
roughly approximately in a big picture
sense house loan algorithm will get as
you add more and more complexity and
squared means that the processing time
goes up with the square of the number of
inputs double the number of inputs and
the run time quadruples the lowest Big O
notation as an algorithm can reasonably
have is constant or one that means that
no matter how much stuff you throw at it
it's going to return its answer in the
same amount of time and O one is usually
something really simple like return the
first item in the list some common
algorithms have a Big O of N or linear
this means that processing time goes up
at a steady rate with the number of
items so if your code needs to go to a
list and just do one thing to each item
in it that would be linear double the
items double the processing time so
let's try some other sorting algorithms
here is insertion sort start with the
second item compare it to the item
before if they're the wrong way round
swap them now take the third item and
compare it to the one before if they're
the wrong way around swap them and then
check again with the one before that
basically you keep moving each item in
turn towards the start checking as you
go until if you find something smaller
and you know it's in the right place or
you reach the start of the list and you
know it's a smallest if you've got a
hand of cards and you are putting them
in numerical order this is the algorithm
you're probably using without even
thinking about it
and yes that is usually faster than
bubble sort but crucially it's Big O
notation is also N squared and this is a
really important decision to make if two
algorithms have the same Big O it
doesn't mean they perform the same it
just means that if you draw the graphs
of how they get worse with more inputs
those graphs have the same shape for
both bubble sort and insertion sort if
you double the number of items it will
quadruple the runtime but with insertion
sort that run time is usually shorter to
begin with now I'm not gonna go into the
details of every sorting algorithm there
are a lot of them but there are two I
want to flag up the first is quicksort
choose nine time on the list and call it
the pivot then go through the list
putting anything smaller than the pivot
somewhere to its left and anything
larger somewhere to its right
once that's done you look at just the
ones to the left of the pivot
you do the same you choose a new pivot
and you split those and you repeat that
divide and conquer all the way down and
then you do the same to the other side
of each of those pivot points and work
your way back up and the worst case Big
O notation for this is still N squared
but the average performance on a random
list is n log n I'm not going into the
mathematics but suffice it to say that
is a lot a lot better and then on the
other end of the scale there is bogosort
which is designed as a joke bogosort
is really simple randomized the list is
it sorted great if it's not randomized
again and keep going until it's sorted
the average performance there is o n
plus 1 factorial
you can draw a graph of all the common
Big O notation to compare them but the
important thing is the Big O of whatever
you're coding is going to be most
affected by the worst one of those that
you have any wearing it if your code
does 10 operations that are linear and
one that's got a Big O of N squared well
your program is N squared now remember
it's just an approximation it's a guide
for humans to work out which algorithm
is best to use
despite being about computer science
it's a little bit fuzzy so what should I
have done with my search system back
when I was a kid well I could have used
code that was already out there realized
that other people have done the work for
me that's true but ultimately what I
should have done is what the client
asked for typed the descriptions into a
word processor and save it as a document
because that was a better solution they
could have just searched it by pressing
ctrl F textin doesn't break down on the
updating one operating system gets
upgraded if they have new photos to add
anyone who knew how to type could update
it they could still open that document
today the big problem wasn't that I used
a bad algorithm the big problem was that
I was ignoring what my users actually
needed because I wanted to show off how
clever I thought I was it's important to
think about how fast things will work
sure but the best solution isn't always
the fastest or the smartest it's the one
that works for everyone long term this
series of the basics is sponsored by
dashlane the password manager and
there's one aspect of password managers
that I haven't talked about in these
sponsored sections yet protecting you
against phishing attacks
this is a slightly embarrassing story
but let's say you've signed up to
dashlane which incidentally you can do
by going to - Lang comm slash Tom Scott
for a free 30-day trial AB - link
premium and let's say that at some point
later on you are exhausted and tired and
you click a link to view a Google Doc
that someone has shared with you and you
get asked to sign into Google and you
just assume that your session is timed
out for security as it does sometimes so
you type in your email address I'm
saying you here but this literally
happened to me because I was exhausted
and not thinking straight so let's say I
did that and then my password didn't
autofill because the domain name wasn't
right it wasn't a Google page and
autofill checks the domain that you're
logging into if the domain doesn't match
it won't type your password in for you
and that was the clue I needed to wake
up and realize that actually that wasn't
a real login link and that was a really
close call the people trying to pull off
a phishing attack only have to fool you
once now password managers aren't
foolproof there is always someone more
foolish I could have assumed something
was broken in the software and tried to
copy and paste my password instead but
it was enough of a red flag enough of a
warning that I saw what was happening so
- Lang comm slash Tom Scott for a 30-day
free trial of dashlane premium which
includes unlimited password storage and
sync plus a load of other features and
if you like it you can use the code Tom
Scott for 10% off